more than 23 000 songs are shazamed
every minute in the world
but how does it identify the music
around you after recording just seconds
of audio from your phone
Shazam has to create a unique audio
fingerprint of what you're hearing and
then search its database for a matching
fingerprint that means simplifying sound
to a bunch of data that can be processed
incredibly fast
this is the tech behind Shazam
the idea behind Shazam is simple take
the audio captured on your phone and
convert it into something a computer can
easily compare to other songs in
Acoustics this is called audio
fingerprinting simplifying a song to a
unique signature that you can identify
even through lots of background noise
the first step to creating Shazam was
digitizing a large amount of Music since
there was no existing database it could
use we literally hired about 30 18 year
olds to work eight hours a day and three
eight hour shifts so 24 hours a day
actually putting CDs into computers that
ran custom software that we built from
the ground up we had 100 000 CDs which
is about 1.7 million songs because CDs
don't contain metadata they had to type
the name of every song every album title
and every Artist as they built this
massive database once they had digitized
each song they had to convert them into
something that looks like this a
spectrogram spectrogram's map out
frequency content over time they also
display signal power level related to
how loud something sounds which is
represented by color in this special
gram of Birdsong we have time
progressing to the right as is always
done in special grams and then frequency
on the vertical axis so this is coming
down
you know that's not the right frequency
Zone but that's the idea Julia Smith is
an Emeritus professor at Stanford center
for computer research and music and
Acoustics he was also an early
consultant for Shazam and assisted with
one of the company's early patents with
music spectrograms often look more
complicated than this because you have
to deal with harmonics or overtones
which get softer As you move up from the
fundamental frequency Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony the opening measure is and then
the next hole measure is Bomb so this is
the classic
in score and then over here in the
special gram we have the same thing not
as clearly written but clear to hear and
that is
[Music]
Shazam had to match spectrograms like
this it would take an incredibly long
time to return a result the first key
Insight was to focus on peaks in the
spectrogram because those Peaks are the
main thing the brain processes Shazam
simplifies a spectrogram like this to a
scatter plot of Peaks many of these
Peaks make it through background noise
but you may also end up with a bunch of
additional meaningless Peaks so let's
say we have a spectrogram of a piece of
music and then we look at the Spectrum
and how it changes as noise gets brought
in so let's say people start walking
into the bar people start drinking a lot
people start making a lot of noise then
what you see is the original spectrogram
plus a lot of new activity and the brain
is very good at understanding
superpositions of sounds if people can
do it then the computer can do it right
the core of shazam's technology is
matching Scatter Plots that essentially
chart the most powerful signals at
different frequencies over time it also
develops some important processing steps
to speed things up so you can get a
result quickly
instead of searching its database for a
match of all these points in the proper
sequence Shazam looks for multiple
points at once and doesn't worry about
the overall sequence until the end for
example say you were in a coffee shop
playing classical music
you open Shazam and it records your
audio
first it makes a spectrogram like this
then it isolates the Peaks and makes a
scatter plot like this though in reality
it would probably have more points
Shazam connects nearby Peaks to form a
bunch of pairs then Shazam searches for
matching pairs in an organized database
of millions of songs if there are enough
matches in the same song and they're
aligned properly over time Shazam can
name the tune in this case a specific
rendition of box Minuet and G major
after about two and a half years of
development Shazam launched in 2002 well
before the smartphone era everyone was
carrying these mobile phones around
everywhere and really you could only
just do two things with them you could
make phone calls and you can send text
messages and I guess you could also play
the game Snake here's how Shazam worked
back then this is one of its earliest
pitch decks initially Shazam was a
service that people in the UK could
access by dialing 2580. after recording
15 seconds of audio the call would
disconnect and a user would get a text
with the name of the song while the
fundamental algorithm has stayed the
same Engineers have made some
modifications to improve its recognition
rate it was good enough that it felt
like it worked most the time and it
really delighted people that it would
work in these like bars and clubs and so
on we also had to then add additional
tweaks to deal with the fact that music
in the real world also gets adjusted in
terms of speed Tempo and Pitch so there
are for example DJs might adjust the
speed of music when they're playing
vinyl records Shazam wasn't an immediate
hit it had to sell some of its patents
to fund development though it later
bought them back and it wasn't
profitable it says until 2016. Barton
was CEO for four years before stepping
down though he continued to serve on the
company's board when I left Shazam it
was running through a long period of
barely surviving Shazam was a story of
nearly failing nearly going bankrupt
incredible resilience over many years it
didn't really hit a hockey stick of
incredible user adoption until the App
Store launched in 2008. eventually
applebot Shazam and 20
now one of the most popular free music
apps in the App Store once you're paying
for unlimited streaming of music what is
it you're actually going to listen to
because you have access to everything as
much as you want and Shazam solves one
form of Discovery you're not only
discovering music when your friend tells
you about a great band but you're
actually discovering it in your daily
life the technology behind Shazam has
grown significantly since Apple's
acquisition in 2018 when it bought
Shazam it also gave the company access
to Apple music's large library today
Shazam can identify most of the Apple
music catalog of over 100 million songs
we created an App many years before apps
actually existed part of the art of a
startup is the timing aspect and so
fortunately we found a way to survive
through those tough years
[Music]
foreign